وراء الضربات اليومية وحرب المعلومات،
هناك غضب يؤجج التكهنات حول
شخصيات روسية رئيسية، مما يجبر الكرملين
على تبديد الشائعات مثل تلك التي تدور
حول الزعيم الشيشاني المتشدد رمضان
قديروف الذي يظهر الآن على التلفزيون الحكومي وهو يلتقي
بالرئيس بوتين بعد شائعات عن
شائعات خطيرة نشرتها أوكرانيا
المخابرات وهو ما
نفاه خضروف على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، أنصح بشدة
كل أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون التمييز
بين الحقيقة والأكاذيب على الإنترنت
بالذهاب في نزهة في الهواء الطلق
وترتيب أفكارهم، كما كتب
في الأسابيع الأخيرة.  كانت مشغولة
بإنكار المزاعم الأوكرانية بأن ضربة
على مقر أسطول البحر الأسود في
سيفاستوبول أسفرت عن مقتل العشرات من
ضباط البحرية الروسية بما في ذلك
القائد العام، لكن الأدميرال فيكتور سوكولوف
سرعان ما ظهر في مكالمة فيديو غير مؤرخة
مع مسؤولي الدفاع الروس، وكان مظهره الصارم على
الرغم من أنه أثار
التكهنات حول منصبه.  أخيرًا، ظهر
الأدميرال وهو يوزع الميداليات
على فريق كرة القدم التابع للبحرية الروسية وهو
يجيب على أسئلة حول
الهجوم على الرغم من عدم تمكن CNN من التحقق من وقت
وقوع الحدث، هل
يمكنك من فضلك أن تخبرنا في بضع كلمات
بما حدث لطمأنة سكان سيفاستوبول،
لم يحدث شيء لـ  تستمر الحياة الأمريكية يقوم
أسطول البحر الأسود بتنفيذ
المهام الموكلة إليه من قبل الأوامر، لكن
الروس البارزين يميلون إلى
الإختفاء من حين لآخر عن الأنظار، حيث اختفى الجنرال
سيرجي سوروفيسين، وهو قائد روسي كبير
مرتبط بفاغنر،
بعد تسجيل بيان يدعو إلى
المرتزق.  مجموعة للتخلي عن
تمردها مرة أخرى في يونيو/حزيران، وبعد أشهر في
سبتمبر/أيلول، تم توزيع هذه الصورة
بزعم إظهار سوراه
فيكن وزوجته في موسكو في محاولة
لتبديد شائعات عن اعتقاله وحتى
وزير الدفاع الروسي بعد وقت قصير من
الغزو الشامل.
اختفى رئيس أوكرانيا العام الماضي عن الأنظار لأكثر من أسبوع،
وظهر مرة أخرى في نهاية المطاف في
مكالمة جماعية عبر الفيديو مع بوتين، وهي إشارة
ربما إلى أنه عاد لصالحه.